marie 42 ans souffre d'obésité depuis
son enfance il y a deux ans et demi
cette yvelinoise a connu une opération
pour se faire retirer les trois quarts
de l'estomac
je suis sleeve et depuis deux ans et
demi je suis obèses depuis que je suis
enfin gto baisse depuis que je suis
enfant j'ai fait le parcours sleeve
parce que j'ai une gonarthrose au niveau
du genou
donc j'avais un poids à perdre important
et très vite j'ai perdu 30 kilos donc
bah c'est une réelle renaissance enfin
parce que je peux de nouveau marcher
bouger plus facilement et puis c'est
surtout toutes les douleurs que j'avais
dû à mon genou que je n'ai plus en fait
aujourd'hui marie continue à être suivi
régulièrement par des spécialistes
on a des visites de quotidienne au début
tous les trois mois après ça c'est à la
six mois puis après un an avec le
chirurgien bariatrique
par contre on a toujours le suivi
nutritionniste donc là c'est bull et moi
moi j'y vais et un suivi psy qui est
hyper important après une opération
comme celle ci perdent 30 kilos en
quelques mois c'est pas rien c'est pas
anodin et qu' il faut se faire
accompagner parce que notre corps change
notre vie de famille change nos
habitudes alimentaires et autres change
en fait toute notre vie change en sur un
court temps en fait
du coup c'est hyperimportant vraiment le
suivi psy je m'attendais pas dans un tel
changement aussi vite et est ce que ça
allait pouvoir impliquer aussi dans ma
vie familiale et dans ma vie même
professionnel enfin pour tous en fête
depuis son opération marie a vécu
plusieurs moments difficiles et
notamment les périodes de confinement
suite à la crise sanitaire
c'était stressant pas pour pas pour ma
santé pour way pour le fait d'être à la
maison et du coup d'être plus à côté de
la nourriture en fait au quotidien ça
c'est plus compliqué en fait quand on a
été au bez parce qu'on finalement on se
bat toute sa vie contre ça c'est pas
parce qu'on a été opérée que bas que
tout est facile et que tout a changé en
fait ça reste au quotidien compliqué
pour moi le plus dur c'est de se battre
contre tous les vieux démons qui nous
attire et qui j'ai envie de dire qui
nous attirent votre frigo c'est sain
c'est voir faut alors que quand on est
au travail c'est plus facile parce que
ben où on n'a pas cette ses envies tout
le temps en fait à ce jour mary n'est
plus considéré comme personne à risque
elle devra donc attendre pour se faire
vacciner